hello and welcome to sidetrack your
sci-fi tv a movie channel uh my little
bit that i said the start of every
episode i am joined by stormy bear over
there now resident america and i'm going
to push right through stormy bear's head
and joined by matty over there
the hell yeah he is
moved during the intro bit which is very
disorientated but today we are going to
talk about
stargate sg1 series 2
and i'm going to make the argument here
guys and this might be a little bit
controversial but i'm gonna make an
argument that this is the most important
series of the franchise and actually one
of the best series of any sci-fi series
ever
which is maybe controversial but it is
such a good series and we're gonna we're
not gonna obviously spend the next seven
years talking about every single episode
because it's a 23 episode series
but we've picked out a few of the
important ones
and we are going to talk about them
and we're going to explain why there
happens
there was about nine episodes we were
talking about nearly half of them yeah
i i really struggled to there's a couple
of episodes i'm gonna say right now that
i really struggle to um to knock out and
not talk about
um show and tell where were the ray two
suicide squads these invisible aliens
that got into the base and was trying to
kill everybody i
i would love to talk about that message
in a bottle is a great episode
family where braytac tells a posit
apophis has kidnapped rayak and tiok's
son
uh the gamekeeper is a vr episode i'm
not we're not going to talk about that
there's spirits with the native
americans and aliens that look oh god
oh yes let's not talk about the native
americans ever again no let's just leave
them out on it how could you
there's the episode holiday where
michelle i was easy to drop back it's
not very good episode um
don't think oh well i say not a good
episode compared to the rest of this
series which was phenomenal
um and obviously there's tokra um i
don't know i say that with some weird
accent there's the toker episodes part
one and two um i haven't listed that
either
but it's brilliant episodes i just
couldn't believe it there's so much goes
on in the episode we could do an episode
a video just talking about those two
episodes to be honest yeah so
um
but what we will start on guys if if you
don't mind is the serpent's lair
written by brad wright directed by
jonathan glasner
is part two of the
uh for me
a finale to a series part end of part
one series one
you know you got the mirror episode
where
you know they see they see the
alternative thing and they and the and
they see
the gold attack the earth and then they
come back and then it's really three
parts that's it that episode um and this
is the the finale of that we see the
gold walled busters you know the first
naked or enriched nuclear weapons um oh
smilers in and he finished so so you
know what we're talking about tomorrow
we're good we're good excellent um
so but uh the serpent's layer is the
season opener for
season season two episode one it's the
third part of that trilogy of episodes
so this is where we actually see
sg-ones on um the one attack
they then right at the end of the relays
episode they've got c4 on the attack and
they're about to blow it up and they
realize there's another attack which is
apophis's like um flagship so they
realize oh well if you blow this one up
they'll still do it so we'll go what
we're gonna do
um and
this episode they have that brilliant
thing where they um they have the
grenade they have the gold flash grenade
and it rolls in and knocks them all out
and braytac
is in the episode doesn't mean it's the
first time we really see braytack a lot
um and he goes ah
that's not a grenade and then later on
um
o'neill pulls a bunch of grenades and
throws them into the core of the ship on
the other one isn't it and then they're
gonna pull
one of my favorite parts of that episode
have you got any other favorite parts
you wanted to mention before we go into
why it's an important episode um
the shuttle's comment i like
the uh are the bray tech we've got a
couple of shuttles are these mighty
warships
are these are
but then actually in the end they become
massively important yeah
um
the couple of really important bits on
this i think is um
obviously we we find about chlorelle
and the dude with the big hair that gets
um turned into apophis's number two we
see that in these episodes
the bit that's important to the rest of
the series though is this is actually
when the towery get their hands on
a couple of death gliders
which obviously then comes through the
rest of the series a lot you know that
were they obviously that's when we i
think it's one of the first times we
actually get a hands-on goal technology
that we can then like you know use so
it's a hell of an opening episode a
minute we also see the whole thing with
the alpha sight and
repeat of bits from the mirror episode
so
what do you guys think of the episode
and like say written by brad wright
directed by jonathan glaser kind of the
dream team it
yeah the two
rarely go wrong
there is an episode later but
again with a little i'm going to get
yelled at but i it's one of the one of
people's most favorite episodes and i
don't like it but we'll talk about it a
bit later
the next episode i wanted to talk about
because we're going to whip through this
when i got an hour boom boom i'm getting
the comments guys an hour
an hour stormy sure whatever you say bro
the stormy american hours are longer
than british hours
electric system
tell us what episodes you loved from
series 2 and why you loved them
the next episode i picked was in the
line of duty
written by robert cooper directed by
martin wood
do you guys remember this episode at all
that's sam carr
joel in our episode isn't it this is the
john our episode so this is the episode
where
um sam and sg1 are on a planet and
they're rescuing um some people from a
gold attack and you see sort of like uh
you know um sam carter goes over and so
it hits her neck and so it goes in her
mouth and then she's just blood blood
myth coming and then her eyes go
like you know they don't explode their
eyes don't go
her eyes glow in that way does anybody
want to explain to me why the gold ruled
when they invade a host have such an
easily identifiable thing like their
eyes glowing this is just like like the
thundercats model yourself when we're
kids and you push the back in the art
and
i looked this up actually before
something to do with they add a synaptic
nerve
into the host that connects to them and
it's the way of them connecting to the
whole science
so why does it generate light
well my my theory is that's just the way
gold react when exposed to compound v
i okay
um and then they take the ring to mordor
and they live longer
compound v isn't that from the boys
yes
i'm binging it i'm sorry
blink blue why are you even inviting me
here today i don't know i don't know you
didn't make enough people angry last
week
um
one of the things we saw in this episode
was the ashraq assassin that goes after
we never see that again do we in the
series i don't think
it's this special assassin that goes
after sam or goes after jolin r i don't
think we ever see it again we what was
do we not see him in that episode where
with the
jafar and the tauri
is it terry or is it okra
jafar and the token living on that
planet is like an ashraf i'm sure
there's nash right there oh is that
actually okay i don't remember seeing
them again but i say somebody in the
comments will tell us
so i was just wondering if it was if if
there's those assassins that group of
assassins was only uh in a hypothesis
group
could be or whatever they call them we
do see assassins again they were like
bounty hunters and things in lots of
episodes don't we well you know yeah
um
off our world base okay
um
yeah
um that is the first episode where we
get to see the um
the top though isn't it and the the the
gold aren't all bad
um
i don't think it particularly explains
it particularly until the toker episodes
which we're not going to talk about
yeah unless you make me if plants are
nice you know that the
the bad the big bad of the series is not
always
that bad there are offshoots yeah it's
i like that little twist on it isn't it
that it's it's like
we're not all like that and some of us
think another way but even then they're
still kind of pricks which is i always
quite like that you know the the top
aren't like compost very popular yeah to
say the least
is that one todd particularly no let's
not go into that um
um and actually then at the end of that
episode sam um is saved by
jalina who gives her life for sapphire
another reason why that's such an
important episode though is that that
that we that comes back through and back
and back and back through lots yeah i
think that really does solidify the
stance of who the tokera are
because previous to this we haven't
really seen to go all old being that
selfless you know
and i think in terms of
you know jack and the crew
seeing oh my god a go old with with you
know a selfless act we should pay
attention to that
and i think it really is as well and it
really added a
you know a kind of a
i guess a plot uh a plot metaphor like
it you know now we have to search out
okay which one's the bad one which one's
the good good one what's that protocol
and it sets up a number of storylines
just from this one episode
exactly no yeah and i just love that
that obviously sound that really
affected sam and changes sam's character
as well
um as it should have done because
obviously jealous memories and
everything like this were then became a
part of her and she and she's obviously
able to use gold technology and stuff
going on as well
that was an important plot point in the
lots of episodes and she's actually able
to use the healing technology and things
like that
um the next episode i picked
is thor's chariot which was just the
best episode
it's just stunning it's the first time
we actually see the asgard
um
we see an asgard mothership that is
much
much bigger than anything we see it must
be like the jj abrams
asgard ship because it's enormous
compared to everything we see in any
other episode
um
bigger is always bigger
that is science that's just one-on-one
as you can't argue that
bigger is always bigger
one thing i never understood about that
that episode
obviously i know the ship is huge
but yeah it takes everything including
the ship
where does it go
yeah because uh you mean the weapon
the the when the ship comes over
obviously there's a there's a gold
mothership landing on
three years ago yeah just landed yeah
there's a few of them
and it takes all of them as well as all
of the
jafar and all that but where do they go
because i don't think that's god would
kill them would they
i think it's beam technology
so that's it it's it's like the um
so so like the wraith
darts how they put them and then they
store them in the buffer in the
transporter buffer
um i just leave them there forever
you know that thing and then they well
no i suppose i could take them somewhere
else and just like relocate them and i
like now stop being naughty land you on
the planet [ __ ]
yeah you're going to get a notified
hedgehog in the garden you put it over
in the fields
stop don't cross the roads bad hedgehog
um
i saw a hedgehog the other day much
bigger than i realized oh they are huge
i had one in my house once i've never i
don't i can't remember the last time i
saw one in real life it was freaking
enormous yeah
um
there's anything else about this because
i i love that episode because i'd love
that was a throwback from thor's hammer
from the first series when like you know
sg1 had actually gone out and
deactivated this divide this weapon and
then the gold were allowed to attack
these norsk people i just i'd love that
i'd love to throw back to the original
episode
like can i ask you a question about the
hedgehog
no
um
is is
because here that all the hedgehogs i've
ever seen at least in america they're
little tiny fuzzy well not fuzzy little
prickly little things that fit in your
hand
yeah this is about
like about a foot big it's not that big
oh maybe i think hedgehogs are about
that big this thing well they usually
you're not talking about a groundhog
correct
okay they are generally like this big
look like when they're outwards clad
ones running around and they're spiky i
mean if you shaved all the spikes off
imagine they're quite a bit smaller but
yeah less spiky so oh it's a european
hedgehog it's a specialized species a
little bit bigger than the american ones
yeah just which is better obviously
you're so jealous of our hedgehogs
americans love everything bigger
so
come over here take them out here
every single time yeah it is 100
touchstone was the next episode well i
said we'll we'll bath through the pixel
but then we'll talk about why this is
such an important series yeah but
touchstone um i think it's the first
time you see the nid actually up to no
good the national intelligence
department
and the madonna weather
um device but i've seen that this is
one of the most important episodes
because it's where we actually only ever
get the reference of the feelings
that we never actually get a reference
to them or uh it's only one of like one
of twice or three times they're ever
mentioned
and they're they're supposed to be the
fourth species it's the knox the asgard
the ancients and the furlings were the
original species that stood up against
the asgard and we never see the feelings
other than
colonel o'neill later talking about the
imagines they look like the ewoks from
star wars because
that planet where him and maybe went to
it was heavily implied that that was
something to do with the violence well
that's the only deal although it was
never confirmed so yeah i think yeah
i was thinking about this before elmer
uh piped in on chat i thought there was
like a stargate atlantis
uh episode where they mentioned them
they might have done but again they they
were mentioned a handful of times which
is
actually um
the furlings are prime to come back for
whatever new series brad wright thinks
of
if he's allowed to
do a show um well you know that you know
that spaceship at the uh what are coming
what season it's probably the end of
season three
you know when upoffice's um ship and
uh our attack that we now have um get
sent to another galaxy and is that we
had for about five minutes
um we went to the other galaxy and then
there was that ship i think that's the
fernands
yeah okay does again it doesn't
reference it though specifically
we never see them but
see any other advanced race that we've
come across
so i think i think
i mean the bulk of that episode is about
the id wasn't it and the the weather
device and and mate when we learned a
bit more about mayborn but really the
interesting thing for me has always been
the furlings reference
maybe
maybe such a good one such a good
character the later on episode where we
see him as the king of this little
planet and and yeah you'll have to live
there so like that's such a good episode
you know
he they really did cast him well maybe
the character of mayward i mean
the actor just i mean he just when he
gets in character he just reeks of slime
you know and just
he's like an advertising executive
that's gone wrong i think that's really
what you know a weaponized ad agency i
think that's what mayborne is because he
just you want to punch him you just want
him
yeah well he's got a smile you just go
it looks fake i don't know if it's the
actor or the cast in i don't know but
you know um yeah i'm not sure if it's
the actor or the or his acting but he
has the same smile in it um
of what's it called um travelers
yeah because travelers is another brad
wright project and there's like every
single person is basically from stargate
he's in
that and he's very first there's a
traveler's i got bored of it he's very
um
he's very born in travelers
now this is an interesting episode that
i would like your um your opinion on
stormy as
of sciencey things sciency thing
sciency things science cyancy stuff
um a matter of time
with a black hole
i i i know a little bit about
yeah
and science i i like i like scientific
theories and things but i don't get into
the minutia so i don't understand the
math i don't understand the detail and
i'll be saying that straight off the
back
i watch this episode where obviously um
there's there was a new black hole
appeared um on a planet they were
exploring that black hole there was then
distorting time so it looked like on the
video thing that on the video feed that
they were frozen or
talking slowly or whatever they were all
talking like james t cook
okay
and then
obviously
yeah the um the black hole that was then
plugged into the stargate somehow was
powering it so that it didn't shut down
after 38 minutes so that was interesting
that we got to see a bit more mechanics
of the stargate i thought that was
interesting
how that limit of 38 minutes was because
of power that comes back another episode
but from a
sciencey-widency point of view the time
dilation and things never seemed quite
right to me
and definitely the way that it was
projecting through
the gate
um not the fact that it did but the fact
that the way it works never quite seemed
right to me
do you guys think okay
okay so
as a story
it worked kind of well right
uh
we would have to um
okay so
the effects of gravity is based on
mass and distance let's say you have two
objects
the closer they are the more the
attraction is
uh the bigger they are the more traction
is so when you combine
the the d the the distance is very close
and the mass is very close and you can
get great gravimetric distortions
now
the way the gate works as premised in
the series
is that you're opening a wormhole from
one place to another
and i think i haven't studied this i
haven't read anything about it really
it's
anyway
we have to accept
that the time that these guys are on the
planet the sg team that's on the the
planet that's
being torn apart by a localized black
hole
that that time
that gravitation
when it gets let's say gravit the
gravity is one g at the uh
star gate with the uh off world next gt
is one let's assume it's a one well we
also have to assume that the gravity
also equals one throughout the entire
distance of the wormhole right
okay so
when it gets to earth i mean how many
you know
billions of light years millions of
light years
are they away from so we have to say
well gravity
if if the if in this wormhole somehow
the um
the uh the stargate trans transmits or
or
keeps the gravity
going and transmits it along with the
the material objects the mass
and
i think that's something where the
scientifically they kind of jump the
shark because we've seen you know like
uh
you know i like they will be in like uh
you know bright desert or something and
they'll come through and then it's just
like normal illumination
right
the photons
don't cross over but the gravity does
to me i mean if there is i mean there's
lots of little schisms and there's lots
of videos on youtube concerning like
the physics of of the gravity and the
black hole and you know
uh
jack dangling over the black hole with a
cable that's destructing around him as
he's trying to place the charge or
whatever it was
but for me it was like well how is the
gravity transmitting or translating or
traversing the
the wormhole how's that energy being
transversed i was noticed whether if the
gravity was strong enough that it was
distorting time to the degree that it
did in that video but it didn't
like have any other
i would have thought the gravity would
have to be so strong to distort time by
that factor that wouldn't it
cause more harm i mean it broke a window
but it broke a window like
ages after you know i mean it's like it
was distorting time by days by factor of
10 or 20 or something but it broke a
window towards the end
that was pretty cool that that was
because i'm coming really slowly towards
them i really like that that was because
the the gate basically had a lensing
effect on it so the closer you were to
the stargate
it was coming out like yeah yeah like we
didn't we didn't feel the effects so you
say we were educated we didn't feel the
effects of time but if you were further
away it would have been like days weeks
months you know yeah yeah yeah
that's true yeah it was an immediate
thing going on what you said about uh
how would the gravity transfer
two-way travel between a gate is
possible because we know radio waves
travel to it two ways
yeah
so
i don't know i i think gravity is like
the fundamental force of of the universe
surely that can with it can't be
destroyed you can't destroy gravity as
well as just
maybe still you can
say you can but
as far as i mean you can't destroy
gravity so you can travel both ways
okay so gravity comes from essentially
you know it comes from mass
so if you turn mass into
total if you can totally convert all
all mass to energy you no longer have
mass to generate gravity
something like that that's just my
low level
calculus based physics understanding of
the of how that works
don't exist as well which is a little
bit difficult to get two sciency wines
yeah surely
then there's the whole thing about
wormholes do they actually exist have we
ever seen one you know
you know it's just
dude we're we're still struggling with
uh magnetars you know
yeah exactly
i do wonder if if
matt makes a good point in that it's
supposed to be plugged into the wormhole
that's what's supposed to the world was
supposed to so the black hole supposed
to be powering the stargate but wouldn't
have shredded it by that point but but i
suppose that's getting we're getting
into two anusha
i'm not sure the black hole was actually
powering the stargate
the way i saw it it wasn't powering it
at all it was literally the time
dilation effect
the gate was open on that side but
because the time dilation effect was so
long i suppose so that's why the gate
stayed open for so long i mean the
circuit
it was only like two seconds two three
seconds wasn't it like um between when
that gate opened
it was oh that's a good point that's
good i don't think it's actually power
in the gate i think it literally is just
time dilation just of course it's being
forced to because well that goes into if
we're talking about time travel
an episode that is actually i think
quite popular within the fandom
in the episode
1969 the personally i hate
i don't i don't like it as an episode i
i've watched it two or three times i
watched it again today and all the way
through i thought about this earlier and
i was going to say i didn't like it
yeah well it's not i thought everyone's
gonna say they like it so i might say i
do but
it's it's a funny episode
but i don't like time travel episodes
generally speaking i don't know how time
was affected by a supernova
um i thought the this was written by
brad wright and directed by um charles
corral um but i just thought it was it
was a bit lazy just because they wanted
to
do the paradoxy type thing
um but i didn't really understand the
science so basically the idea being that
the as the wormhole came in it was hit
by a solar flare
that threw it around the sun a few times
superman-esque and that's that caused
them to go back in time to 1969.
um
so it was just a bit of a lazy episode
the the science of it i agree with i
think like it doesn't seem
uh i'm not i'm not a
physicist or
or yeah
why are you on here then
um you are inviting the physicist
dr matthew
um
yeah i wasn't a fan of the episode
but i like it in the fact that it
brought that mechanic into the series
because it did open up a few really good
episodes later on down the line
yeah one of which
it's going to lead into the new game the
timekeeper is going about it's going to
jump through time a lot if it gets
released
um i don't know you know the the the one
thing i think everybody overlooks in
about in this episode is
lieutenant hammond was a hottie
let's just get that right out there
he's an attractive fella
i'll fight you for him
i'll let you in i can't know what it
looks like let's have a look young
i watched the episode today and i have
to admit at no point did i go oh
lieutenant hammond
i'll make some of that steak sorry
i can
the guy who played young hammond
actually is
uh someone called major kearney in
season eight
i remember the major cuny uh character i
didn't realize that he's he's he's
hammond young hammond
no way that's completely off topic but
yeah
um i i do like elements of this episode
though i do like how they turned up at
cheyenne mountain
um and so i thought they were russian
spies which was kind of cool because it
was based in norway it was a weapons
testing facility at the time
um
i like how they did the whole paradoxing
with because it happened the general
hammond knew about it so he wrote a
letter to help them
um
the bit i really don't like is the
cassandra bit at the end
when they step through the gate ever so
slightly too late so they end up getting
thrown
further into the future and they mean to
but because they'd survived it
sam was able to tell cassandra about it
so cassandra's there with a device it's
just a bloop and the stargate does that
thing that they do in later episodes
where it just goes it just goes
and there's no
you know what i mean and it just it
opens it's like it's like
like how the knocks open it the knocks
opening the asgard do it singing who's
more than i think yeah and but then they
then they walk through and then go home
the way they're supposed to so i thought
i thought the end was a bit it was a bit
like ah you know oh
it was like brad wright had written i'd
read a bit on time travel and god
that'll be a good episode and written an
episode around it and throwing all these
little things in about paradoxes and
stuff um
but
but i don't know it just didn't work for
me
and it definitely
going into the next episode it could
have definitely just not happened and
the episode would have been
absolutely fine
yeah they couldn't we think that if we
if this episode was just never shot it
would really not have any uh
impact on any later episode
and story-wise yeah not really i think
it was just a lot of the jokes about
teal having to put a thing around said
and stuff there was just a lot of them
and they wanted to do the whole 1960s
thing
you know please hit like if you are new
to the channel guys please like
subscribe hit the bell notification as
shelly has reminded me to do and if you
want to if you enjoy the content
become a fully fled side track and hit
the join button because that gives me
money every month and the wife gets
happy and won't um
make me stop doing it
um i've already suggested at the moment
that i should become a house husband
stay at home and just do this full-time
and she should look after me financially
um and that was um
her retort to my plan was that what's it
gonna be like living at your parents
house
and i'm just like
i was gonna say how many nights did you
sleep on the sofa for that one
the thing was i think she thinks i'm
joking and they're going i'll have the
housework done and dinner would be ready
when you go home i'd be a brilliant
house husband i'd be amazing
but anyway i'm not allowed
so the final episode of the series
me and matt are gonna i think we're
gonna argue on this a little bit oh god
i think it's a complete stinker
no no i i don't know i'm not shut up man
i'm talking now
um
out of mind
is the episode that it's a two-parter
end of season um if you compare this to
the serpent's lair at the start the the
the two or three-parter at the end of
series one in series two this whole end
the season it's an opening for season
three is it
is crap
um but o'neil wakes up he thinks he's in
the future it turns out he's not and he
thinks he's been a stasis doesn't he and
he thinks it turns out he's not it's a
goal plan to gather and tell and it
actually is a filler episode because
there's a lot of flashbacks and stuff
through it
as a filler episode it's quite a clever
one i think if this had been a
mid-season filler episode i wouldn't
have had a problem with it
um but because it was an end of season
episode
i had a problem with it and also hathor
turns up at the end and i couldn't stand
that character i thought she was crap
oh i've got love gas
it's like a batman 1960s batman bad guy
did you say la i've got love gas she had
love gas
isn't that basically she belched and
people fell in love with her isn't that
basically how it works hey that's
totally wrong
okay never mind
i can't even
just never mind cut off my camera
i think
i'm sorry man i can't say your name what
is that peter that's an
amazing name um
as as a clip episode as a filler episode
it's stunning as a fine season finale
episode it's awful
and that's my point um half our r.i.p
in love guess
see
i agree with you on
out of your mind being a terrible
episode
i'll just see what you typed
i'm just shocked
i'm the one to shark i was just like
yeah
what
is
it's just a terrible episode
yeah so i i
i i'm not a fan of out of mind i do like
this
for season three though i like the
second part
because it's not a clip show that's the
only reason i don't like out of mind
it's because it's just a clip show i
mean club shows let's just
they're they're kind of lazy you know
yeah
i think
24 episodes i don't mind a filler
episode if you do it cleverly and
stargate actually did do some clever
ones remember the president one yeah
well they have a new president and he's
reading the reports
yes and they have and they certainly
their little flashback bits that i
thought was a really clever episode
again it's a filler episode it's a you
know the actors really need a week off
episode
um but if you're doing 24 episodes
i i'm okay with it i don't mind
the difference with those ones is there
were they weren't a finale or an opener
yeah exactly that's the point yeah it's
a mid-season thing isn't it yeah
that's why i don't like it as a finale
it's not useful
i mean the cliffhanger is good
sorry
the cliffhanger is really good
in the fact that he gets that's a jack
gets turned into a gold
i think one of the cool things about the
episode where we have the new president
and explaining all this to him
is it really kind of his reaction to
everything
it kind of really defines the character
over the rest of the time he's there you
know it's just
you know he doesn't give in he he does
he starts you know he listens to the
team he listens to the science
instead of the crazy
i can't remember the character's name
though you know what's his name
was that an ex was that was the um 200
wormhole extreme episode a filler
episode
it's a brilliant episode i'm not sure
it's a film thank you i think it is the
episode it was basically brad wright is
this as the writer as the is the lead
when right all the writers all you guys
you with no show has ever done 200
episodes before
go crazy and they did and they went
crazy
i'm not sure it was a filler but i agree
with you it's a brilliant episode
um but yeah i think we can agree on that
one then that it's a flashback episode
and that is really weird to have at the
end of the series
but to jump back so that's the entire
series in a nutshell that's the that's
episodes i picked out but you know we
didn't talk about but an episode we
didn't talk about
which was it was which was probably my
favorite episode of the series
is serpent song
which that this is the episode where we
see apophis
um
so we see apophis die for the first time
is it we die is he died for the first
time like three times we see him die
about three times i think
um the last time i think we see him die
is because our replicators yeah
over him
and even though the replica has never
killed anyone that you actually see you
just hear people go
um from behind a door and then they i
don't know what the replicas do with
them but anyway um
the story for the the plot basically
though is that apophis has been attacked
and defeated by soap
who used to be on earth and they used to
these two like to call themselves satan
head of satan
um you said
yeah
um
i'm just in your private message i don't
know what you mean we'll have to ask
about it late
but anyway um so serpent song was
written by catherine powers who actually
wrote a few really good episodes in this
series and directed by peter de luis
um
it's the first time we see about the
iris because so car i'm sorry i'm
getting ahead of myself so
apophis we think we're we've had a
message from the tokra and we go and
investigate and then a death glider
crashes and it turns out to be a profit
and he's been um
tortured
using gold technology and he's he's he's
close to death so when they decide what
to do with him they decide what we'll
take him back to earth
and we'll we'll watch him die and we'll
poke him while he's dying and go
while he's dying and stuff i'm thinking
pretty sure that's what it's actually
um
so they go they go back
there's there's lots of really nice bits
in this episode though
um what do you guys think of the episode
do you remember the episode
yeah
i watched this one
a couple of weeks ago absolutely loved
it
the
thing that i liked the most about it was
as apophis the guard was dying
it was he was in such a weakened state
that the host was able to finally come
out and it was something that a sad ex
like watching it i felt sad for the host
because he obviously he's been there
since the egyptian transfer what like
5000 years
yeah
he's been trapped in an endless dream as
he describes it himself and he was a
scholar
um he just wanted to see his wife and
kids again
and then the whole scene with daniel
sending him on his way um with the
egyptian prayer thing was quite nice but
the
the thing that i
think really does set up something good
for the series is the fact that it gives
daniel hope that the host does survive
it's obviously because his wife charlie
and scara at this point
they're both still taken by um
by symbiotes
so it just gives that extra it just
gives him i think that that uh peace of
mind that the host does survive it does
it's not
nothing of the host um survives as the
goal would like to perpetuate
absolutely i think this gave daniel's
character a lot of hope
because
they've only had the interpretations of
what's really going on in the
sarcophagus and in the body of a gold
infested human
they've only had the gold side of the
story you know maybe a little bit of the
topra and they never
you know there was always the tucker is
already always a consensual bonding
and especially when uh carter's dad gets
sucked in or
translated or squirted whatever and he
kind of becomes tokresque
they you know go back and forth right
they can have the conversation you know
the the the the
topra uh symbiote can talk or or
carter's dad can talk you know so
there's that so they only had those bits
of data points and so then when daniel
actually sees someone that was violently
non-consensually taken over by go old
they're still the host is in there now
it may have been probably hell for the
the the host but
i think it's really i think this is a
really big turning point or
you know in injection of hope for daniel
in his search for charade nice
definitely and just quickly on thank you
shelly for the contribution it really it
really does help the channel and like it
really does keep my wife happy she does
ask how much i earn off youtube every
month and i think every month hang on a
little bit less she's like should i
allow this hobby i do think that that
thought is creeping in so honestly
anything that helps the channel really
appreciate it i agree i completely agree
with you guys that scene
is so powerful
when they um when he he switches and he
the the the host um comes out sort of
thing
um and it just showed his acting ability
as an actor as well the guy that played
up office was just phenomenal
um it does actually make you and that
whole bit really would go where he's
dying and he's aging as well because
obviously the the
um the the gold power to regenerate the
body is is is waning as it gets weaker
and weaker
um
the the reasons i love that though so it
told us so much more about the gold
world we learned so much more about the
gold walled in that episode than we ever
did really in any other episode
um it was really emotionally very
powerful
um
and it was one of those episodes it's
just a really beautiful star game that
was so clever from beginning to end it
was such a clever episode
and then we got the whole thing with
socar um projecting them through the um
through the iris and talking to us um i
love it when baal does that in later
episodes and um
and balls just stood there like
this and then o'neil comes in and he
goes
you've been making me wait you think
because i'm sorry i was enjoying a
lovely brunch i was just like but that
was the first time we saw
um him do that thank you so much
um i love that i'd love to love guests
and please please everyone give me the
love guys give me the love guess
um my beers run out i wasn't finished
merchandise at sidetrack.com um so
um yeah then the episode is beautiful um
i love then he uses a particle weapon
against the iris i thought that was
again so close so he's just very slowly
heating the iris up
to until hopefully it would buckle and
then i love that bit as well where he
said they as soon as the 38 minute is up
and then the and the um
wormhole shuts down
they try to dial out quickly
but they can't dial out as quickly as
the dhd
can um dial in so so car can dial in
quicker because they've got the ancient
technology and we haven't got one so we
can't die as fast until
sam thinks out of a quicker way to dial
back out against something so that is
still pretty slow though with the way
they did that and i that always irked me
because i've seen them died on other
planets they just go doo doo doo
yeah but that diamond program was not
that quick
no no exactly
so i mean but i like that how they again
we learned a bit more about the gate we
learned a bit more about the the
mechanics of it we learned a bit we
learned so much about the gold i just
i'd love that episode from beginning to
end guys
but how about my argument
um
so i said john santos 22 so it's not 24
until season eight i think this episode
i think this had 23 episodes
so i think
um but uh um correct me if i'm wrong but
i think it's 23. it was 22 22 20 it was
22. yeah is that clean that top row is
part one and two yeah well uh with my
apologies
yeah toka part one was 11 and took part
2 was 12.
well
you're thinking
was kind of a two-parter but one was i
think
uh you know the andy uh
the finale of season one maybe was that
where but it's actually it's
yeah
i'm trying to look now because i just
don't believe it but i know i'm wrong
it's 22 episodes
so that'll
bad jamie i read 23 somewhere but you
know what these things happen um math
was never my strong suit it's why i'm
not a scientist
like matt and stormy oh um stormy's a
aeronautics scientist and matt is a
physicist as we established earlier
um
um
i do touchy-feely psychology and things
so you know
anyway
um
so the the series as a whole though
i i would argue that it's the best
series in the
franchise not because necessarily it's
the most entertaining or whatever but
but this series really established so
many
really important things for the for the
for the franchise as a whole
um going through the 22 episodes i could
have came to them
um i want to talk about all of them but
we haven't got time because we've got an
hour stormy
sure what did you say
so you know there's but there's so many
things that you know
i mean uh did we talk we didn't really
talk about the fifth race which is such
again such an important episode where
um o'neill gets the that thing goes over
his head which obviously if you're ever
in a sci-fi situation and you see an
alien light coming from a wall the first
thing you should do is stick your face
in it
um
to be fair to him tilt did it first and
nothing happened
well there you go then so neil just went
well get out of the way
he didn't know he had the ata gene
maybe o'neill thought it was some sort
of ancient spa and he just needed like
you know
indian head massage kenyan head massage
you know um pores vacuum sucked or
something i don't know
so it's blackheads
but that was a brilliant episode as well
and it was um that was i loved how he
started having like speaking ancient as
he was going along and that was just a
good episode and we got to see the um
asgard at the end um i don't know if he
sort of goes through and there's just
these little fellas and he said oh hello
um
but you know it's such a really good
episode but all the way through there's
just brilliant episodes in the series
what what what do you guys think about
my assertion that it's the best
series of the franchise maybe
the best series if you think of a series
like an album you know like a music
album this series is like
i don't know called in the shape by foo
fighters or you know never mind or you
know it's one of those
um just just just great because you
could tell my music taste it's just one
of those great
albums
you know
what you're guessing
well i i think that season two was
really really good you know the season
one they kind of
well the original films kind of built
the world built out though the basic
rules and season one really took those
rules and started exploring them you
know in terms of uh
finding out what's out there and trying
to uncover more about to go old
uh i think season two really expands
that
not in terms of the and then i think
this is the reason why it's season two
strong
it's not in terms of like how season one
did it you know exploring the world all
the gate system the
dial out devices etc but here we really
start to explore
the uh the characters
you real a lot of the nuances of the
character like when we were just talking
about daniel you know search for charade
you know i think
season two is more character driven than
season one watch season one was like
stargate tech driven you know and all
this kind of stuff and yeah watches
yeah we really got into the people
i think
really more so than other
series yeah i think we had a couple of
episodes in the first series that sort
of we started to pad out characters
and the episode where they end up in the
antarctica in the first series i think
you really got to see
richard dean anderson and
um
i'm sorry o'neill and samantha carter's
characters develop a bit more but yeah i
think you're totally right um like um
andrew just said
by the end by the start of series two
o'neill's character was really
embedded in so it wasn't it we we knew
who o'neill was
sam's character
changed a lot and this and daniel
started to become a bit more
of a rounded character rather than the
little geeky fella that we saw in the
first series but yeah
with daniel's character he
he stopped doing the james bets spader
impression
um after
yeah
towards the end of towards the middle of
the series series really had a haircut
and
after that he was
the daniel we know in love
yeah i love the movie but james spade is
daniel was great
but the the new daniel the reader yeah
the reborn daniel yeah i just loved him
kept elements of it didn't he kept
little little things like with the
glasses and stuff and he kept little
things but he became actually a useful
character if they couldn't keep the
james spade version could they because
he wouldn't be useful in a week in week
out series
um so but they had to change the country
but yeah it did take i agree that he
stopped doing a james spade or
impression a brilliant james bader
impression it was very good yeah
but it didn't feel like
um it didn't feel like
it was like an instant an instant switch
it was very progressive like it didn't
it wasn't like old he's james spader on
this episode and now he's daniel jackson
as michael shanks in this episode he was
it was very like
and i'm wondering if you know uh the
characters change
is the directive result of
losing charade you know in the first
episode you know he's the you know he's
got the um
that 1.0 kind of attitude you know from
the original stargate film
and but he slowly starts translating to
the new daniel
and and i'm thinking it's just you know
he he really takes it seriously he takes
it this is no longer an academic pursuit
you know he's got to go find his spouse
you know and he you know and and and
well
jay's a psychologist here he can
what would be the uh the the kind of the
mental changes of somebody that would
lose a spouse and how much would their
personality change from let's say
someone's a musky old academic to
someone that is still an academic but
still knows
but really gets good with a rifle you
know you just get very good with the
pn90 really really quite quickly
throughout series one um
which is good because people keep
shooting at him a lot
uh
you know
and in the first episode he basically
dies in series two as well and he has to
go into this sarcophagus and we get
regenerated so
but no i completely agree that i think
that point about the james spader
impression i think is is really
important i think by the end of the
first series o'neill has become o'neill
i think richard dean anderson they very
consciously had an evolution from
um the kurt russell version to him and i
know in his contract when richard
johnson signed on to she went i want
this character to be why he's cracking i
want him to be this this
he needs to grow from the original
character which i think is actually just
an evolution of what you see from kurt
russell from the beginning of the
stargate movie to the end it's just then
continuing that because he is different
character by the end
kill himself he was this far from often
himself
less suicidal more thing
um
yeah uh god we could have ended up with
another audio kurt russell movie um if
uh if some people have had their way but
um
and they i think they did the same with
zhang and jackson the second series it
was like danny was daniel was allowed to
michael shanks was allowed to evolve
that character a lot more in the second
series yeah and i think that's important
but i mean that there are just so many
things in this series so that we get to
that that laid the foundations for so
many things the holiday episode that we
didn't speak about with marcelo that was
the first time we see him and we see
actually i can ancient
even though that's not sort of like
you know specifically points that in the
episode we don't really know what is i
don't think do we but he's supposedly it
doesn't end up being merlin in the
industry it's the same supposedly the
same character
um
the holiday episode um like i said
that's sorry that's the holiday episode
the poker episodes who didn't talk about
is so important there's just so much in
this whole series that
they come back to you know in later
episodes in later series even even into
the aura series they're still
referencing this series because it's
just it's just just fantastic
it was very good for
character building um but
also
the relationships that the tower you're
gonna be having moving forward so
the asgard the toe crew obviously a
massive part of that but then
even relationships with the go award
themselves as well
yeah the second
the second you said all right it just
hit me america's turning into the aura
yes they are but blessed are they all
right so um
that's okay
and blessed is america in god we trust
may the seed fall
yeah
through his
we all know what's going on in america
this this week no we don't it's a [ __ ]
show here oh my god i actually tweeted
him americans are lovely
american legal system is mental
um but
but anyway that is uh our show about the
first series before we get into that
the second series review um please get
in the comments guys tell me exactly
what you think of series two i'd love to
know what you think yeah really not not
about the things you're thinking about
stormy
um
amy's supposed to move into new zealand
whoa really
that's amazing for once glad i live in
australia
i i honestly think my wife wanted to
move to australia a few years ago nigel
saying why would you want to live in
australia
um everything hates you in that country
if you go inland into the bush you will
definitely die if you go to the ocean
you will definitely die if you go into
any river
you will definitely die so crocodile
will eat you if you go to the toilet um
a red back might jump out from under the
rim and bite you in the ass and you'll
definitely die
and there's been a drought for like 30
years
everything that country hates humans
and then and i still want to throw
another shrimp on a barbie and go live
in australia but
constantly i spider scare me so i'd be
in constant fear
i'd love i'd love to live in new zealand
though that would be amazing um it looks
pretty
hawaii i'd love to live in hawaii's over
there's big spiders there but as well
don't like spice
um but anyway
so
what have you guys watched this week
just out of interest just by with just
where we end the video because we've got
four minutes
so
go ahead man
oh i've been watching the expanse
that's been made for a long time to be
honest the first season the first few
episodes the first season up were really
slow
and i was i wasn't sure if i liked it
um so i did the whole the whole thing
you do when you're watching new series
you google is it going to get better
and everyone's saying
uh wait until episode four uh or five or
whatever
and then they make up your mind and by
four i was hooked so
i'm on season two now yeah the first
series was fantastic the second series
started really slowly because you're
like well what happened to everything
that's happening in the first series is
that is that done now
and then the second series sort of
started completely different direction
you know it did take a little bit of
time to sort of get into it it opens up
and you're like oh there's a longer
story arc going on here yeah
like no damn proto monokio man yeah
that's awesome yeah well if you go back
and check out my previous video you'll
know that obviously there are very very
strong rumors and i'm being told there
are very strong rumors that it might
return but it'll be that was the reason
i started watching it i watched your
video
and
i've got to watch it i'm going to start
watching it
yeah because i've been recommending it
for years but i never i've never
i don't know i just never never i
finally got paramount plus
finally got paramount plus there's three
episodes of star trek strange new worlds
i'm gonna be honest
i don't particularly like it
so
i'm gonna i'm the only person that
doesn't like it just not too like i do
like it but it's there are elements of
it i think um i i can see i'm worried
about the future
the the the thing i loved about the very
first episode was the idea of a warp
bomb
yeah i like that idea i don't know how
that works but
yeah of that
yeah so i've been keeping you know watch
the latest episode of um
brave new worlds
um
uh i caught back up with the orville
grill growl growl um
also been heavy into
uh
the boys i finally made it to season
three
finally fourth episode of season three
is the best episode of the boys in a
long while don't spoil that i've not
seen an episode yet
well there was this uh
she sells for just one minute they they
had to shut i mean i don't know what
happened
but there was something that went on in
in season three
that um
a lot of parts of the
i got no idea is he in the shower he's
being beamed up by the oscar no i think
so
so but there was this uh
outrage
in the reddit community for the boys
they had to shut a bunch
a bunch of threads down boot a bunch of
people a lot of people
shut down their account and is mostly
right-wingers in america freaking the
hell out because all of a sudden
they thought they were rooting for the
good guys
and they turned out to be
somebody else
but i'm thinking
really
it's just it took you this long
have they not watched the boys have they
not seen season one and three
and so i i i don't think i got to that
episode yet but i can certainly see
where it's going
it says i'm on episode i think i've
watched the first episode
so far i've got so many shows i'm
watching at once i'm trying to catch up
on the flash i'm watching the expanse i
give up for the flash about 15 years ago
so would have been about season six
i'm now about five um i gave up in the
first few years ago but it's just such
good i keep seeing little bits online
about it like i wish i was watching the
flash but there's so many serious now i
can't be asked to go back to the start
yeah there is a few seasons i think uh
between scenes what we are now season
eight see
season nine maybe i'm not sure but
anyway the the the season before this
and going back to like season five
they're not very good i always watch
them because i love the flash he's my
favorite superhero um
but this series is actually all right
mainly for the fact that my favorite you
know flash villain is in it like a lot
and any
any property with him in it like legends
of tomorrow arrow you know if he's in it
i love it
yeah
okay so so i've i've got to make a a
comment about the casting
for uh the boys so it seems like they've
drawn heavily on uh the cast of the
supernatural
right
you know with
soldier boy and
dean
uh the other one is you know they got
carl urbane in there right and then they
also had an episode with john noble
you know and and the thing that was that
and they were both in lord of the rings
fellowship of the king and so is
the return of the king and so what
really kills me is john noble kind of
plays the same character chooses one
brother over the other don't you have a
different script isn't there a different
storyline you could act with and i was
just i was chuckling on the couch and
it's just like
you tossed one brother away in favor for
the uh and it was just like
well where does gandalf come running in
i mean
does does gandalf work for vaught i mean
what's going on it just it made me
turtle
yeah
i think it's shocks sometimes there's
the bit where um in the last season the
um homelander is um
pinning that guy against the wall while
he makes sweet sweet love to the nazi
chick and gets over excited and crushes
his head oh that's so gross
it's so gross so good though
it makes you go
with the very first episode you know
when he's holding his girlfriend's hands
on the um on the on the curb and a train
comes and just blows her up because he
hits us so hard so fast something
i think
that second episode
where they
they put the bomb up
uh what i can't think of his name
translucent i think his name was yes
yeah inside of him because they couldn't
penetrate his skin and he's just he was
like you're not gonna you're not gonna
do it you're not gonna do it he just
goes boom
and he just blows up
blood all over his face that was like
literally that episode made me fall in
love with that show
did you ever watch him spartacus years
ago
yes
i'm thinking i loved that show but that
was yes boys is kind of similar to me
every so often i go
oh i shouldn't like this
okay if you don't do such and such there
will be words yes exactly like every
other episode that was the line yeah
spartacus was from the same in the
comments a couple of people mentioned
the writing's not as good as it should
be um
uh i i loved preacher as well aliens and
stuff that's preacher was such a good
show the first season in particular is
amazing but but the writing isn't always
as good as it should be but it's such a
clever concept in its simplicity
and it is basically if you give human
beings flawed human beings superpowers
we will probably not become superman we
would probably all become some version
of a super villain who wants to be loved
we'd we'd hide it but herogasm is
something that would a 100 percent
happen and if you've not seen the last
episode i've just ruined a little bit
for you but i wasn't going to watch it
um but it's it's 100 we we do think with
our penises we do want people to like us
but actually we're quite greedy and you
know inherently i'm not sure most of us
if we had superpowers would become the
good guy i think a lot of us would
become the bad guy
did you ever watch heroes
yes yes
yes so this serious phenomenal heroes
the character of sylar
yeah absolutely loved him is the perfect
example to be honest about what would
happen here if you wouldn't think there
was a movie a few years ago as well
about um
a superhero that was a young kid and i
went through and i can't know what was
called video that was a good film and
it actually a young child who is
horribly egocentric um just wanted what
he wanted now
um you know and stuff and when he's then
when his mom tells him he can't have
something he he flies off or or pops her
head like a balloon or whatever this is
like you know could you imagine that
kids having super powers
it wouldn't be like that other brilliant
series of um what's it called uh saving
uh raisin
dion raising arizona saving private ryan
listen dionne dean raisin dion i almost
said raisin arizona two times in my
brain but i stopped myself i'm raising
dion who's this little kid who actually
wants to be good he does want to be good
and he's a good he's a nice little kid
i'm like ah you know the first time your
mom said no you would pop a proper brain
i think that's the tragedy of homelander
though isn't it
he
he was very much a child who is who was
indoctrinated into this um
voor
experiment and he just lived in that
room didn't he yeah he lived in a room
you you saw it on season two he just
lived in that room and that's why he's
so [ __ ] uh messed up i don't know if i
can swear on this i'm not going to
we're talking about the boys the c word
is their favorite word
my wife won't watch it she hates that
word she absolutely detests i'm like
this is such a good show let's watch
this all up and turn up straight turn it
off
guys starfighter has a really good point
dark matter on netflix is awesome needs
a fourth season
i actually agree with that he's a fourth
fifth and probably sixth and seventh
season that was a really good show i
really don't remember what joseph
is it a what
was involved in it wasn't yeah oh oh
right it is isn't it is it yeah i've not
seen it
but i wanna
i'm pretty sure it's something to do
with one of them brad wright or jessica
it's on my list
that's why i'm watching the ex the
expanse at the moment because someone
when i used to work um at the place i
told you i worked before jay yeah
one of my colleagues was like oh you
need to watch the expanse it's basically
it's like it's like as good if not
better than stargate and i'm like okay i
need to i i'll i'll try it i watched the
first episode i was like this is just
[ __ ] i don't want to watch this
yeah i think this is going to be too
good
matt here's a question for you what's
your favorite ship so far in uh
the expanse do you have a
favorite
are you kind of that kind of a viewer
uh favorite ship
i don't know i'm on the episode at the
minute with you know the mormon ship
oh yes yes i like that
um and what's happened yes big boy it's
spoilers for anyone who's in the expanse
by the way um but the asteroid has just
moved and i've so i think i'm on like
actually three or four oh you're a
newborn
the razorback's not just with my
favorite ship and the expanse it's one
of my favorite ships
most sci-fi i want a razorback
yeah
i've just done a video about my favorite
sci-fi shifter which is um
uh the gun star from the last
starfighter and i've just recorded a
video on that that'll be coming out next
week at some point can't we need to take
a moment to talk about the b wing from
star wars from last
gods
i mean yeah okay if you want
you know so this guy was giving me all
sorts of hell in the uh chat or in the
comments
yeah last week
you know i was quizzed about well
do you know about the beef the b-wing
from uh star wars
um
not off top my head i didn't recognize
you know the the b-roll i mean i i don't
i don't spend a lot of time you know
studying the starships uh or the
spaceships in star wars because i build
spaceships for a living
anyway
right
so anyway i went to look up the b-wing
it only appeared for a brief moment in
episode six
know what no other episode no other
tv show has been well comics and web
comics and video games
and audio books and regular old books
and it was just like no i didn't recall
the b-wing right off the start and i
really do apologize for that then you
build um spaceships so they're going to
fall apart for a living
don't like it i'm going to do a video on
it i don't like it
you need oh oh we watch it i love it
only for the final episode because it's
oh the final episode
oh dude geez
i'm telling you the final episode
there's a scene there that i was
actually scared of darth vader i mean
absolute real emotional fear as a cause
it was
dude
seriously
that was a jedi
at the moment i've watched five episodes
i've only got the last one to watch and
so far just about there episode 6 is so
good it's the best one
i'm going to do a video on it once i've
watched the last one because i'm going
to be a bit cocknumber so it's not
working and i i think one thing about uh
the kenobi series
is um
i think it shows hayden christensen's
acting chops
when you know george lucas isn't
directing him
just saying yeah
okay you remember my theory my past
theory is like once we got out of
episode
uh
out of the first three original
uh once they got her back around to
phantom menace
there was nobody left in hollywood to
tell george lucas no
and so i think it
suffered a lot but hayden christian
scared the [ __ ] out of me before we go
back to andrew markle's question which i
would love to i think would be a nice
way to end the episode do you remember
battle of the planets the cartoon back
when we were kids not you andrew you're
too young
uh not you sorry for matt andrew uh
that's your little baby you probably
wouldn't remember the battle of the
planet's cartoon was so good they were
all wearing like things and they look
like birds their helmets look like
birds beaks
think i'm really oh the best cartoon but
the phoenix would turn to fire when it
was like in a battle sort of thing it
was like oh it was so good
um google it guys if you ever get a
chance watch you oh
i remember this
brilliant cartoons were so much better
when i was a kid g-force right to defend
earth g-force yeah oh man i i've seen
that
youtube it it's great it's fantastic you
probably have to revert to being a 10
year old to enjoy it properly but
i think i can do that
i i'm well in touch with my inner child
to end the episode then guys so this i
think is a good question on a stargate
video
when the new series comes around out of
the three different gates we got to see
in the different series which is the one
you want to see return
so you got the sg-1 the mechanical
the sgu actually if i move you can see
all three gates look there you go
there's all three um you've got the sgu
gate behind you don't you
like that led you want that's the
atlantis with the big codes underneath
the atlantic sorry i meant atlanta my
brain thought atlantis in my mouth said
universe
and then you've got the universe one
which is actually the one that's
there my favorite gate is the atlantis
gate because i just think it looks nice
and it's a lot more functional yeah um
but
that being said if one was to come back
i would pick the original because it's
the original
yeah yeah i think uh the uh atlantis one
it was had the best design you know it's
aesthetically the most pleasing but in
terms of functionality i would like to
see the sgu gate to come back just
because of its
extra addresses you know
yeah
for me i think it's very limited though
understand what you say there because
yes the sg-1 gate which is my favorite
and my best and i like the mechanical
nature of it
but yeah it's limited on addresses
apparently the original energy
sorry now this will add that apparently
the original sgate is cheaper than
tender
okay
thank you
nobody isn't
i don't know if you've been reading chad
but there's some crap going on in chat
i i've missed some oh my god yeah
a lot of deleted wisdom
contender that shouldn't that needs to
be my uh saying for the last
i need to put that on my uh
linkedin it's cheaper i am also cheaper
than tinder
so florence likes atlantis i mean
you know
that was a gorgeous uh gorgeous city and
a gorgeous ship was the atlantean city
not a brand shame
i miss it i'd love to see atlantis make
a return the actual city i mean
well on july 27th and we're going to all
be taking part in the twitter storm
where we're going to do hashtag and
bring back we want stargate so hashtag
we want stargate and everybody around
the world we're just going to go ah
twitter
and i'm sure that'll work
and you can also get inside trek.com and
buy we want stargate merchandise which i
make no money off but
go on twitter and do all that and and
make things i should have made money off
it didn't think it through it's i've
sold a few units now and now i really
wish i'd um made money off it
um but never mind um there's a greater
course
i got a star uh stargate universe
question for you guys there was a series
of comics that picked up where the
series left off have any of you guys
seen those or read those yep
is it full of coral goodness or should i
is it worthy of me going right it's it's
mixed
so um i do like how it went along the
lines of where the third and fourth
season was supposedly supposed to go
in that we saw actually that aboard the
destiny
there are a bunch of ancients in stasis
that they've never got to when they wake
up
is the big chunk of the
the series
i did like that and they're not
particularly happy when they wake up
these are real
ancients they're not projections or
holograms
million years ago they have been stuck
in stasis so the whole idea was when
atlantis when destiny got to where it
was going they'd be brought out stasis
um but obviously the destiny was a seed
ships who was planting stargates along
the way so it could think but it was
there was a purpose for where it's
supposed to be going and i think that
they all point with us they were
supposed to be like engineers so they're
waking up because the destiny is about
to
completely break down sort of thing so
um
so yeah so um
but yeah it's good it didn't really have
a
like a conclusion that i remember
i don't think they ever got home but
they yeah i did have there was only like
two two books weren't they done
the back to destiny series is that what
were you talking about
yeah i forget what it was called
actually but yeah it followed universe
so it was the comic books that followed
the universe but it was so it was guided
by melody in some ways at least that it
was supposed to be included bits where
he
he thought the series was going to go
so um but it's beta cannon so it's
doesn't that did it
did it ever um deal with the questions
lingering about uh eli's or eli and his
outcome
we saw that eli survives
okay um he's um he and and we figure out
how as well he'd shut down the power and
he started to cipher power
from
um like an energy field that surrounded
the ship because they were ftl he
started siphoning off that to get more
power to and then he is able to wake up
some of the crew
here's some of the stasis pods but some
of the spots failed
so um yeah yeah
that's it really
i read it about five years ago rush rush
is woken up
still
but um i really love the rush you know i
mean you know he always had his i mean
he wrote so much and that little tiny
notebook was so small i mean he was
going just he was writing all the time
he's like
dude
you don't have enough paper for a whole
season i'm just saying
this shows the whole you know rush
tunnel with all the other equations he's
been writing and i thought i i
as as flawed as rush was he was kind of
my favorite character yeah i think it's
a good point i never consider that they
couldn't get more paper could they
unless somebody happened to remember to
bring the bunch
tell me little shirt pocket notebook and
a pencil
never occurred to me
she was always furiously writing
i'm trying to smell if my dinner's ready
something's cooking i can smell it so
thank you so much guys for attending
stormy as always you you brought the
magic
oh you're just flirting uh hey as always
sir
um we're not woke on this channel we
don't mind a little bit of uh man on man
action
we can play rugby in our shorts
rugby's always playing the show it's a
freak
um we should play it in g-string
g-string rugby that could be a neat
thing i'm gonna get the welsh play in
that
side
g string rugby
the americans versus the welsh
i'm not welsh
um you're just associating
we always we all know
let god help you
the old yorkshire geek who's got his own
channel please go and join him he's
starting quite new in the whole
youtubing world
and please go and join
my mate stormy on his channel on cy
works um i haven't put a link in the
description because you weren't coming
on but you are you actually got a link
on the home page if you look at the
little diamond and he's put the um it's
linked as the um
the resident american and you can go
straight to site where it's on there
and but i will add
um watch out for the titty twisters
andrew thank you and matt
tell us about your channel mate quickly
before you head off
i do doctor who related content so if
you like news spoilers reviews anything
to do with doctor who in the upcoming
60th anniversary special
come and say hello
um easy way to get to it is just type in
youtube.com
him h-i-m-2
it's an old url
mcn and they gave me a custom url but is
it matt dean films
no no just matt dean uh if you go on my
facebook group he's got a you've got a
link to it on there haven't you
i do but give me a second i'll just post
it in your uh
you also manage our reddit page you also
manage our discord page there's also
links to those on the main channel so
please go and join those it really helps
us out and and we well that doesn't
actually help the channel out at all but
it gives you guys a community to go and
actually talk about this stuff
so i mean that's that's lobster anatomy
with matt dean
how
not me that's not me
maybe mandy to come with lobster anatomy
with matt dean
the great lobster so we've established
in this last year that i'm a physicist
and a lobster
enthusiast hey i just want you about the
discord man i started a pl um i finally
uh got hooked into the uh
minecraft world yeah
i've been having a blast but i find
these the the at the spawn zone there's
these secret doors at the corners i'm
trying to figure out how to get into
them or oh what's that you
yeah sport knack man oh that's you okay
i don't i don't know i do not know
anything about the spawn i downloaded it
from planet minecraft
it looked cool and i was like this i'm
going to put this in and then
if you can't give me god mode or
something because i want to get through
those doors it looks enticing all little
stairways i see but i can't get through
because i don't i'll i'll come on and
i'll have a look
thank you see are you playing on the on
the uh minecraft server jay
i don't i have not been on the minecraft
server i haven't played minecraft in
about five years
i got a little cabin built now off on
the way i just
i'll try and get on there but um i used
to i used to play minecraft with my
daughters a few years ago but then they
grew out of it and to me
between this channel recording videos
editing videos watching size fights so
i've got something to talk about
and having a wife and children that
demand to my attention regardless of how
much i however much i tell them i hate
them i want them to leave me alone
to talk to me
um i you know i don't have a lot of time
it's it's it's phenomenal how
time-consuming having
um a youtube channel it's
it's incredibly time consuming
so i got put the discord server up as
well there you go
so yeah all of these are linked on the
facebook channel and they are normally
on live videos but um i didn't do it so
um
i didn't have time today so
thank you boys thank you for joining me
thank you for everybody in the chat
um i'll put a link
alien stuff check the video in about 20
minutes and i'll have a link for it for
you okay oh thank you alien space
there you go aliens spaces the chapter
you remember when we did the live in
video um
and uh stormy where we invited people on
and we got we got a little bit of gay
porn on that on the on the channel
accidentally who's this alien
aliens in space with the chapter julian
just actually talked to us for a bit
well we can chat about lieutenant
hammond a lot
yes we can and he's the guy that's got
that wall with all the toys and
everything that was amazing we were all
like me and you were both like oh you
got some collectibles there dude
absolutely amazing
right i am out of here so because the
wife is going to divorce me and i can't
afford her to divorce me because she's
the main breadwinner so because you're
not the house husband yet
not not yet however much i'm trying
trying begging really but um thank you
guys everybody for joining we will see
you next week me and stormy going to be
talking space battles or something
have a good one guys
bye be safe have a good weekend
same as usual i've got to remember where
the outro
you